>> KOLEDA: All right, everybody. I'm going
to get started with the next presentation.
My name is Eric Koleda and I'm a Developer
Programs Engineer with Google on the AdWords
API team. Today I'm going to be doing a presentation
of the BulkMutateJobService. So, this is one
of those free services that you may have heard
about in the V2009 API and I'm just going
to go to some details today about what it
is and kind of an overview of how it works
and how to use it, what are the different
pieces of this puzzle are. So, first, we're
going to start with what is a BulkMutateJobService?
As I mentioned, it's a new service and it
allows for the scheduling and running of BulkMutateJobs.
Most of like all of our services are usually
named with the entity that you were networking.
These jobs--the main job is to contain large
batches of operations. So, they mainly hold
operations which means that you will pass
into a mutate method normally, and remain
to process a lot of that until the services
[INDISTINCT]. And its terms are a little confusing
from the last--the last time I gave a presentation
but it's meant to do this work asynchronously.
Now, asynchronously, I don't mean that like
a SOAP level like it's going to ping you back
when it's done, but rather that much like
the V13 report job service--reporting service.
It allows for the work to be done, not while
the request is over. So, you set up the work
to be done, you're paying for the status,
and then you'll get the results. So it's unlike
a regular mutate request which you send the
request and then get the results all in one
transaction. Now it's spread out over time.
So, it's asynchronous in that sense. And really
this service is just a different way to accomplish
the same things you're already doing. Just
we're willing to introduce any new features
or any functionalities, it's really just taking
what you already do with the same operations
across its length in a different way. So what
is a BulkMutateJob? So, this is what your--you
know, your setting and manipulating. It is
actually a pretty complex object. So what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start at the
lowest level, kind of build it up to the full
job. So as I mentioned at the bottom, at the
deepest level of a BulkMutateJob is an operation.
It's the same operations that you use in other
services and it currently supports the services
we see here with the idea that in the future,
you know, every service that has an operation
hopefully it builds a [INDISTINCT] into BulkMutateJobService
as well. So then you take these operations
in pack and you package them into an operationStream.
An operationStream is meant to contain many
operations and they're processed in a batch
manner. So, what that means is that if one
of the operations in an operationStream fails,
the whole stream isn't committed, so none
of the operations are committed in that stream.
So...the goal here is that if you want to
have certain operations that you want to either
succeed or fail together, put them into a
stream. And besides just that that's just
logic, the other part of an operationStream
is that it defines a scoping entity. So, it's
kind of like a hint to the backend about what--in
what contexts do these operations apply; and
that can either currently be in a campaign
or an account, so you can say, "All of these
operations are relevant to this specific campaign
or they're relevant to this account." And
there are some limitations about how many
campaigns and accounts you need to specify
per job but that's the purpose of the scoping
entity. It's to kind of inform the backend
about where these operations can apply. Feel
free to ask questions along the way but I
do actually cover a lot in the slides so if
you want to hold something, you might as well.
So the next level up from operationStream
is the BulkMutateRequest. A BulkMutateRequest
is meant to contain many streams. And it's--we
also call this a part. So later on, I'll be
referring to this BulkMutateRequest as a part.
And that's because its main purpose really
is to allow your streams to be sent to the
server in multiple requests. So rather than
have to send all of your streams in one request,
like, "Here's my streams," you can send that
in multiple requests. And so, you're kind
of splitting up your entire collection of
streams into different parts. And into this
BulkMutateRequest has an index on it, which
just indicates, you know, in what position
of the job does this part with and so. So
if you have so many streams, if you need to
make three or more requests, you print one
BulkMutateRequest with on either zero, one,
two, and that's how--that's how you get all
of your operationStreams uploaded to the server.
And then in the outermost level's where we
have our actual BulkMutateJob. So this is,
you know, the entity that you're actually
manipulating here for getting and setting
and adding. And it's kind of the main, you
know, the main unit of the BulkMutateJobService.
On this BulkMutateJob, you do have to define
the total number of parts to expect in the
Job. And when you're actually getting it later
on, it's going to be the object that has the
status and the stats and the history and all
the kind of meta-information about this job
that you want to--well, everything else is
kind of just, you know, wrappers to organize
the data but this is the entity that will
have all that export metadata associated with
it. And much like other entities when you
create it, getting unique ID, and should then
be used to refer to it later on just like
Campaigns and AdGroups. So that's a little
bit about the hierarchy. But how do you actually
use the BulkMutateJobService? So now that
we know the structure of the job, what is
the general process in this service? So, the
overview here, you know, it's a very generic
level but I think it gives you a good idea
of the flow. And so, the first thing we need
to do is just get your operations. What this
means is, you know, after--whether you're
generating your operations through some sort
of automated utility or by taking user inputs,
you need to take all of the operations
that you would normally run at once like as
soon as you create them and collect them somehow
into a larger pool so they can be bulk processed.
And so this is really just reusing your existing
logic at rather than exporting them right
away and saving them for later. Now, in this
first example code here, so this is just some
generic sample code about, you know, let's
say you were creating a new TextAd. This is
how you create your operation by creating
the AdGroupAd and then finally the operation.
This is a little bit different than V13. Obviously,
you didn't have this concept of operations
for an AdGroupAd but, you know, this is the
same thing that what we're going to be doing
regardless of the operation. You're going
to be creating your operations first. So this
is an example of a possible operation. So
the next part of the process is to create
your streams. So you've got those operations
and I need to bundle that into some sort of
streams. I've said earlier, one of the determining
criteria of how--which operations are going
for the streams as they're scoping it, so
all of the operations in, let's say, at a
certain Campaign--I guess in certain Campaign
should go with one operation stream where
a series of operations are being swept. You
can't have--you can't violate that scoping
entity contract. So you cannot have a scope--an
operationStream that targets one campaign
with its operations within it that actually
operate against that. So, although it's kind
of like into the backend, you go out with
part two or create that as well. And the other
thing you may want to, you know, [INDISTINCT]
decide about when you're creating your streams
is "Which operations do I want to batch together
and running in that kind of way where if one
fails, the whole thing fails?" The next--and
here's an example of creating an operationStream.
You see it's a very lightweight object. It
just has the scoping entity which is an ID
under campaignID or--and then the actual operations.
Okay, so the next part of the process here
is creating the different parts. If you have
an operation--BulkMutateJob that's not very
large, you can just send everything in one
part. There's no reason and no requirements
to have multiple parts. But if you can only
send so much data over your--you know, your
outbound connection so you don't think your
connections are open for so long, it may not
be possible to send all of your information
within one big request. So, it's a little
bit of balance and figuring out, you know,
what your specific server environment can
do as far as how big can you make one robust,
so it's a little bit of back and forth there
and figuring out what will work. But at the
minimum, you just have one BulkMutateRequest
and then just put your existing operationStreams
in those requests and set the index. So, index
is zero-based and it does affects how they're
processed. So parts that are higher in the
next that have come first will be processed
first. So all the operations in the stream
are processed in order and all the parts are
processed in order. So the order does play
some of that if you do have operations that
will depend on each other. So here's an example
of creating a BulkMutateRequest part. Once
again, the principal object just holds a number
of operationStreams and the [INDISTINCT] the
index of the [INDISTINCT]. All right, so,
next step is actually creating the job object.
So what you want to do here is you want to
use--you want to--you know, you build up your
BulkMutateJob which, once again, is not very
complex. Set the total number of parts that
you plan to put into this job and then call
the BulkMutateJobService "mutate()" method
with the ADD operation. So the first time
that you're uploading a part, you want to
use the ADD operation. For instance, you would
add a Campaign or add an AdGroup. And then
when you run this you'll also get back a result
that includes an ID that you can use to refer
that BulkMutateJob later on. This is an example
of creating a BulkMutateJob. As I mentioned
just the number of parts and then setting
the first part in the job, and then creating
the ADD operation, and finally calling the
"mutate()" method. All right? So, then you
have to upload your remaining parts. And you've
added the job, let's say, you still have more
parts there that needs to be sent to the server.
So for the remaining parts, you're going to
use the SET method so you use the--I mean,
the SET operation. You use the ADD operation
when you're creating a job, but then for the
rest of the parts, you use a SET operation
passing in the other parts. So the job has
one slot for a BulkMutateRequest, one slot
per part. And so, on the first--on the creation
of the job sitting in the first part with
ADD and then upload the remaining parts and
just kind of swap out the BulkMutateRequest
with the next one and then call SET and send
again until all of your parts have been set
on the job or uploaded to the server. This
is the example here of how you would kind
of upload your remaining parts so you'd have
some sort of rule that for each part would
set that part on the job, create an operation
to set operation on that job now that it has
the new part beside of it and then call the
"mutate()" method again. All right, so the
next part here is very familiar to people
who are working with the report service. We
just have to wait for it to complete. So,
how this is done is by using the BulkMutateJobService
with the "get()" method passing in to the
selector the ID of the job that you want to--that
you're monitoring. You can also do a selector
for all jobs and find out all of the job statuses.
And so in waiting for completion, you're going
to run the "get()" method and then there's
different statuses that come back. As I mentioned,
one of them was called PENDING. PENDING means
two things. PENDING means either, that your
job has not been fully uploaded yet, so you
set three parts and uploaded two, your job
will be PENDING, as in, it's not complete
yet. It'll also be pending if it hasn't yet
begun to run. It has all the parts but it
hasn't started yet. I'll mention it later
on but basically every account has a queue,
looks like a report queue, you have a BulkMutateJob
queue and only one of your jobs will running
at a time. So if you've created many jobs,
some other jobs that haven't finished yet,
it's going to remain PENDING until it starts.
So a PENDING, how does it [INDISTINCT] in
that situation. PROCESSING, these are the
jobs you see at the front of the queue and
this is actually running the operations at
that time. And then when it's done, it's either
going to be COMPLETED or FAILED. Those are
the two kind of final statuses. COMPLETED
doesn't mean that everything in it was successful.
COMPLETED means that the job was able to complete
that there wasn't some horrific error that
made us [INDISTINCT] report. There could still
be failures in individual operations, but
as a whole, the job completed. So FAILED is
a much more serious kind of error and something
big happened that [INDISTINCT] the whole job
[INDISTINCT]. So here is an example of how
you would kind of ping for the job status.
You will use the BulkMutateJobSelector, passing
in the ID of your job, and then just do a
loop calling the "get()" method on that selector,
and just determine whether or not it's, you
know, it's still pending or processing or
if it's finished. That's what BulkMutateJobs,
they are meant to be large jobs. So this is
going to take awhile for these jobs to run.
So we do recommend, don't ping it every few
milliseconds because it's going to take a
while. You know, so just kind of space out
those calls so that you don't waste minutes
for questions and answers. So, the next step
here is getting the results. So, unlike, you
know, regular mutate requests where you get
the results immediately, now you kind of have
to retrieve the results. Once as you uploaded
the parts, you know, the kind of download
the results. And so, basically what you do
here is you use the same BulkMutateJobService
again. I think--but you set a resultPartIndex
which is kind of like correlates to your initial
BulkMutateRequest partIndex. So, you're--as
you uploaded a part, now you're going to be
downloading a part by specifying the index.
So, using this "get()" method with the resultPartIndex,
instead of--usually, in back of the [INDISTINCT]
step here, when we were getting the job, if
you don't set a resultPartIndex, all you'll
really get is that outer job shell. You don't
get any of the inner parts of the results,
the request parts or the operation streams.
You're kind of just getting that outer shell
of a job where you've kind of [INDISTINCT]
around it. In order to get the actual results
back, you need to run--you need to set the
resultPartIndex. And now, you get kind of
like a fully completed job with all the pieces
inside of it. And so here's an example here
where, you know, for each of the number of
request parts that we've uploaded where it's
going to set the partIndex, the resultPartIndex
on a selector and then [INDISTINCT]. And then,
we can get the job with the results inside
of it. And then we can kind of add those results
or process those results so you can be able
to do like--you need to basically download
all of your results and see what happened.
It didn't say explicitly here, but as you
can see, this is the structure of what a result
looks like. And you can see it's a perfect
mirror of the request, right? So, before there
was a BulkMutateRequest, there is now a BulkMutateResult.
There's an operationStream. There's an operationStreamResult.
And for each operation, there's an operationResult
so it's kind of a mirroring [INDISTINCT].
And so the last part here, now that you've
got all your results, to figure out, examine
that and figure out what happened. So, an
operationStreamResult or the correlated object
with an operationStream contains these operationResult
objects, and there are different types of
operationResults. So, the one they probably
see most often in [INDISTINCT] is the ReturnValueResult.
This means that the operation completed successfully
and it returned something. So normally, it
can do ADD operation. What is returned is
the entity with an ID, you know, as it's--as
it now exists. So it kind of getting back
whatever you were adding or if you update,
you get back the object that you updated.
So, for ReturnValueResults, it's got a kind
of a strange nesting to it that if anyone
here is using that, it's a little--can be
a little difficult to work with, but essentially
ReturnValueResult has an operand inside of
it. And operand then has the actual object
inside of it. So the operand object, it actually
has a field for every possible entity that
could be returned in it. So it has like a
campaign fields, it has an AdGroup field.
And one of those will have a value. And that's
what [INDISTINCT] about the operation. Now,
I'll show you an example on the next page
here to kind of clear it up. But the other
types of results, there's also a FailureResult
as in the case like you try to apply an operation
and it failed. That FailureResult will have
information like the API errors that you expect
to see in the [INDISTINCT]. Another is a BatchFailureResult.
BatchFailureResult means that that operation
itself didn't fail but because another operation
in that stream failed, it was not actually
executed. So, the batch failure result means
some other operation possibly did not process
because it failed. So, here's a very detailed
example of how you can process these OperationResults.
So in the first few lines, we're kind of just
testing to see what kind of OperationResult
we got back whether it's a FailureResult or
a BatchFailure. And this is where I was [INDISITINCT]
to the screen. And then at the bottom there,
the final case is if it's a ReturnValueResult.
So, as I mentioned, in Java, how that works
out is that there's going to be a "get something"
method. There's going to be like a get campaign
or a get on this operand object. And so, what
we did in this case here is we're actually
just using some reflection where we know what
object we're expecting out of this operation.
And so, we're running it to get that object
method. It's a little difficult to view this
operand object, but there were just some technical
limitations that are required it. And so that's
why. You might have to create some creative
solutions in order to pull out your objects
from this operand. And so, this is just another
screen kind of showing--this is [INDISTINCT]
the documentation so you can see this on the
AdWords API Application. But this is the operand
object. And as you can see, it has these different
fields that correlate to the different types
of objects that could be returned by the operations.
All right so, now that we've seen, you know,
what a BulkMutateJob is and how can you use
it, you know, why would you use it? What are
the benefits of that? So, the number one of
that is cheaper. All operations processed
by the BulkMutateJobService are 50% less.
So, depending on how much you're doing, I
think it makes sense. The other thing that
we mentioned earlier is that it's kind of
asynchronous, right? So you don't need to
keep your connections open while you're waiting
for things to process. So, you know, there--I
think there have been some cases in the past
where you send a large number of operations
at once, your connection get interrupted,
cutoff either by on your side or our side,
and then you normally know what happened.
And so you had to scale back maybe how any
operations you sent [INDISTINCT]. So rather
than kind of scale that back and kind of configure
it that way, you do not have to wait and keep
your connection open while the server has
stopped doing the work. You won't need to
send the information, ping the status, and
get it all out. The other thing that's--I
think is pretty nice about this is Operation
rate limit. So, we touched a little bit earlier
today about quota rate--quota system and rate
systems and GPS. And a lot of these things
can be--you know, like we said, we can't really
reveal all the specifics. So this can be a
little tough to deal with. But what's nice
about the BulkMutateJobService is that it
knows and it applies [INDISTINCT] as fast
as it can. So, if you give it a set of operations,
you don't have to worry, "Well, am I sending
too many operations too quickly?" You know,
"Is this going overboard? [INDISTINCT] a lot
of the process." You just give it to BulkMutateJobService
and it'll apply them at whatever rate is appropriate,
as fast as it can. So, you have much of a
transient failure. And the other thing which
we found out last time from the developers
is that--and we brought it up earlier is,
you know, is there any sort of concurrency
possible. And it turns out there actually
is some concurrency in place right now in
how it operates. So, what's happening is that
operations under different scoping entities.
So if we have some operations of the one campaign
scoping entity, another operationStream on
another campaign scoping entity, those currently
are processed in parallel. So, you don't necessarily
process every single operation one after another.
If they're--if they target different scoping
entities, they're currently processed in parallel.
Now, so to be clear here is that the kind
of the design and the goals of the BulkMutateJobService
was not to get things done faster, all right?
I think a lot of people have that expectation.
And while this last slide can it lead to things
getting done faster? It's not really the end
goal. The end goal is really to kind of take
away a lot of the manual work you have to
do in your program and doing that in the backend
and applying all these rules automatically.
So...
>> And reduce chatter.
>> KOLEDA: Yeah. As we point it out here,
reduce chatter, reduce the number of requests,
kind of just take away a lot of those tasks
and have them done by the backend, but not
that you can get the same number of operations
done in a shorter amount of time. That's not
necessarily true. It may be true in some cases.
It's not really the way you should approach
the BulkMutateJobService. So some of the limitations,
I think we touched about some of these. There's
one job queue per account with a 10 pending
job limit or 10 job limits. So, a kind of
like you [INDISTINCT] queue. And there are
some like kind of numerical limitations about
how big a job can be. So a job can only have
500,000 operations in only certain parts.
And currently, only 10 scoped campaigns for
1 scoped account. So you currently can't create
a job that affects a ton of campaigns at a
time or multiple accounts at a time. It's
kind of limited to 10 campaigns at 1 account.
I think the campaigns number is flexible.
The account is obviously going to move across
the line thing. I think it needs some bit
of changes but these are the kind of initial
numbers that we [INDISTINCT]. There are also
limitations to how many streams you can have
per part, how many operations per part, and
so on. The other thing I touched earlier is
that there's currently no functionality to
remove a pending job, so if you somehow uploaded
two parts, then you suddenly want to stop
for whatever reason. [INDISTINCT] you kind
of remove their job from your queue. And it
can't cancel [INDISTICT]. I'm going to touch
on that. It's something I think they understand
people are interested in. And then the other
one here is that you can't upload an entire
campaign structure on one [INDISTINCT]. And
the reason is that, is that you can't have
one operation that has a Campaign, another
that's an AdGroup to that Campaign, another
that adds an ad to an AdGroup, because each
of those sub-entities relies on the ID of
the parent, right? You can't create an AdGroup
until you know the campaignID that you want
[INDISTINCT] to. And you don't that campaignID
until the Campaign is completed. So it's kind
of a chicken and egg situation right down
there. You can't right at the moment just
create all of the objects for a whole new
Campaign and put that in one BulkMutateJob.
All right, well, I'll be around the rest of
the day if you have any other question on
BulkMutateJobService or you want to start
to writing some codes and use it, I'm here
to help. Thank you.